did you know that you don't have to pay
taxes you can move to another country
and pay zero taxes legally you might
have seen my interview with wealthy
expat who does exactly this for you
they've helped over 500 crypto investors
and entrepreneurs like image and Hamza
lower their taxes down to zero percent
legally and you could do it too in as
little as just two weeks wealthy expat
will hold your hands and help you
throughout the entire process setting
you up in a tax-free country like the
UAE with the help of tax experts lawyers
and accountants so if you're interested
in paying zero percent taxes then just
book a free call with wealthy expat
using the link in the description below
hello and welcome back to the Leia
heilpan show joining me today we have
entrepreneur author content creator and
founder of value attainment Patrick Bet
David welcome to the show it's so good
to speak with you how are you today I'm
doing great it's good to be on with you
I've heard good things about you through
this guy named Adam oh you have this
Adam guy yep yep I know him that that's
good to hear yes well I love what you
guys are doing at valleytainment you
offer so um like a diverse range of
different topics and a lot of value so I
can't wait to get through everything
today so the first thing which I want to
kick this off with is you say something
really fascinating online
um I thought it was really interesting
you said that since you were 10 years
old you've always been an entrepreneur
so what does that mean what does that
look like what are you doing at 10 that
makes you an entrepreneur so I'm at a
refugee camp we had just left Iran we're
living in Germany I don't speak German
uh there's this uh family at the refugee
camp we're in the staff family Yan and
Katarina staff are the siblings I like
the his sister a lot Katarina and the
brother and I were friends who was two
years older than me and he was obsessed
with the new Super Mario Brothers that
was coming out okay so I said listen if
I get the Super Mario Brothers video
game I'll be the only one in the refugee
camp that has it he'll play with the
video game I'll have time with his
sister this was kind of a the strategy
anyways my mom doesn't have money my dad
doesn't have money I go to the local
swimming pool and this pool in erlang in
Germany beautiful four or five poles
massive the owner always struggled with
beer bottles everywhere because Germans
are experts in drinking beer so I said
I'm going to clean this place up for you
if I bring each beer bottle in what will
you give me said five Penny great so I
did the math the new Super Mario
Brothers had just come out this is 89
and it's 249 marks 249 this is 1990 I
think 89 so I said 5 000 beer bottles at
five fennec is 249 marks her and
Katarina got to work 30 days later I'm
at 249 250 marks we went about the Super
Mario Brothers from uh cow falf which is
like our uh Walmart and then took it to
the refugee camp Jan fell in love with
the video game his sister and I were
together all the time and then from that
moment I realized anytime you want to
make money you can figure out a creative
way to make money and I never stopped
making money since 10. it sounds like
what really pushed you was the fact that
neither of your parents had money so I
want to talk a little bit about your
background
um you moved from Iran to America
because of the Iranian Revolution
um and I want to understand what it was
like growing up in America as an
immigrant and I asked this because a lot
of people use being an immigrant as an
excuse for not achieving much in life
but obviously you've had tremendous
success so how is being an immigrant
helped you become more successful and
maybe aided in your entrepreneurship so
you know first of all there's benefits
to hard life right you got a very I got
four kids right now and I try to explain
to these guys you're not living a normal
life and I have to figure out a way to
make their lives a little bit harder and
it's not easy to do so I'm not one that
buys them gifts so if you ask my kids
does your Daddy buy you gifts all the
time they'll tell you no my dad's not
big on buying gifts but experiences
spending time challenging and pushing
then disciplining them it's a completely
different story so being an immigrant in
U.S at 12 13 years old I can't pronounce
the word Wednesday is Wednesday I would
always say the D I can't pronounce the
word Island because at that time the Big
Show was Gilligan's Island so I would
say Island I would ask the teacher why
is there an S here we don't need an S
just put i-l-a-n-d yeah it's Island but
you know they decided to put the S there
uh it wasn't easy you know it was it was
tough you had to learn how to get along
with everybody but at the same time if
you don't know any better this is all
you know that's the life you're you know
uh uh having to deal with it's not like
you have a choice to do anything else
but then later when I joined the army
one of the best things when I joined the
army was I was the only Armenian
Assyrian from Iran in the army with
people that are white black Hispanic
Asian from Mississippi South Dakota New
York Chicago Miami Texas and I'm from
L.A it was a fast track on how to win
friends and influence people because
they're judging you automatically where
you're from I'm from Iran why are you
here never forget one of my sergeants
asked me a question he says so where are
you from I said I'm from Iran he says
why are you in the U.S army I said can I
trust you he said of course I said you
know just between you and I I'm a spy
I'm trying to take all your training
back to Iran and for a minute he felt I
said of course I'm not a spy I'm here
because I'm in the Army but you have to
learn how to make friends you have to
learn how to break the ice you have to
learn how to build relationships you did
not have a choice so I think it probably
forced me to have to learn how to get
along with different types of people and
obviously that's helped me out in
business but but something about Emma
immortality right that pushes people to
strive more than people who are from
that country there's no question about
it you know there's no question about it
because this is a dream like for me I'm
playing a game like this is not real to
me I'm in the greatest country in the
world where I have the where I have the
opportunity to use my talents and
relationships and contacts to see if I
can compete in a Marketplace and I'm
willing to work certain hours where my
peers are now we were talking about
earlier your relationship with your
brother and how what that Dynamic looks
like you know in most of America
nowadays we're going in the era of the
four hour work week what can I do to
only work four days a week you know even
the pandemic we learned that a lot of
bosses were saying well you know the way
we do it is you can work from home for
the rest of your life matter of fact
that's what Twitter said Twitter was the
first company to announce that you can
work from home the rest of your life and
they announced this a year and a half
ago you can Google this and you'll see
it and then now a guy named Ilan which I
don't know if you've heard of this guy
he buys Twitter and you're definitely
not going to be working from home
working for Elan but also at the same
time Twitter is going to grow when a guy
like that's an operating it so the edge
you have to be willing to pay the price
that another person is not I'll never
forget I'm coming up in the insurance
industry I'm 25 years old
this one lady who was a former
accountant married good Market educated
degree I got nothing and she says you
know you have to realize Patrick you're
not at our level you can never compete
with us and I said there's one thing
that you don't have that I have and I
never told her what it was but I know
deep down and said there's one thing and
it's the most intimidating thing when
you go against the competitor and it's
the fact that that person's not going to
stop if you go up against most opponents
most of them have a number or a
lifestyle where they'll stop meaning the
moment I have a million bucks Boom the
moment I have five million Boom the
moment I have that house Boom the moment
I'm married with kids Boom the moment I
worked on there's there's always at the
moment I I will be cruising and I'll be
more kicking back I'm not planning on
stopping there's only one person that
can stop me and it's the man upstairs
and if he says you can keep going I'm
going to keep going so the concept of
immigrant mentality and knowing the fact
that we're not going to stop it's a big
Edge you have in a in a capitalistic
Society yeah I really believe there's
something about coming from a privileged
lifestyle which
um
takes away your drive there's nothing
like having no safety net which just
pushes you to never stop like you said
but that's fascinating about the US
military I like what you said um that
you're a spy so what was the actual
reason as an Iranian that you'd want to
join the US Military and also how did
that then um Aid you in becoming an
entrepreneur well you know I love this
country I love America but also at the
same time I had a 1.0 GPA in high school
I was not a good student I was not good
in class uh I was 880 out of my class of
a thousand graduating students you know
I was 880 and so nobody ever if you go
back to my high school and you talk to
my classmates they'll tell you nobody
ever thought Pat's going to do anything
nobody so I was my counselor said
military is a good option Jesus Guerrero
was following up with me from the
recruiting station and finally I said
listen I want to go into the army one
day I made a decision
call my dad take me to the recruiting
station I went to the recruiting station
they had just stole my car I told the
guy if you if you get me to the Army
tomorrow I'm in uh they couldn't do
tomorrow but six weeks later or
something two weeks later I was in the
US Army best decision I made at that age
but what did it teach you
Independence hard work get along with
different personalities conflict
resolution working under pressure uh
right before a problem seems impossible
to fix uh it teaches you to stick with
that problem for another hour two three
hours and then all of a sudden you're
like wow we never thought we were going
to resolve this issue but we did uh the
relationships knowing uh who breaks
under pressure who does not how to talk
to somebody that's breaking Under
Pressure how to challenge the ones that
do well under pressure to do more
because you can get more out of them
it's a lot of different things it's not
one or two things military is is a
constant and by the way you'll talk to
it I went in the army with a few of my
friends my two friends will say nothing
good about the military but I think the
world about the military and we we were
pretty much stationed in the same place
life-changing decision I made do you
think more people should go in and we
would see
um
more men being men if they went in if
you see what I'm getting out here yeah
I'm totally with you I just think look I
got so when you're talking about
privileged my kids live a privileged
lifestyle my mission is to figure out
how to get them to maximize the benefits
they have to go to the next level right
now we're working on one topic every
time I'm dealing with a challenge that I
want to get better at we turn that into
a course so business planning workshop
that we do is because I want to master
the art of teaching my guys how to do
business plan so sales leadership
seminar I wanted to be a great sales
leader so boom you know a strategy
business strategy we did an event we
wrote I wrote a book called your next
five moves I got a business planning
book that's coming out with penguin
right now but the next one is
generational wealth because the concept
of generational wealth is two-tone right
to one of them is you making
generational wealth two is making sure
it passes down to the Next Generation so
if you look at the Vanderbilts and at
what one Point Vanderbilts were known as
the richest family in the world there's
not a single Vanderbilt today that has
money and even Anderson Cooper who comes
from the lineage of Vanderbilt his
mother told them just so you know even
though we're Vanderbilts you're not
there there's no trust fund for you so
you're not a trust fund baby I don't
have any money to pass over to you you
got to go figure out to make your own
money so Cooper made his own money right
but Vanderbilt's at one point they had
150 000 square foot vacation home who
has 150 000 vacation on them right but
the parents were rich but they didn't
know how to pass the money down so
continues you look at the Medici family
who is able to continue the money over
and over and over again Vanderbilt's
lasted two generations I think
Rockefellers are on three I think
medicis won seven or eight the Roth
shots are continuing there's a lot of
The Waltons are in second generation
right now third generation right now so
for me I have to figure out a way to
create that challenge in times for my
kids even though they're living that
privileged life so going back to these
men that you're talking about what they
need there's no question many to be
tougher there's no question men need a
tough personality in their lives for
example a coach that kicks your ass
could replace a drill sergeant a father
that challenges you to do certain things
that doesn't make any sense that give me
a break why do I need to do this it
doesn't matter like for me with my kids
the moment you turn six years old under
by David family you're required to read
20 pages every day that includes Sundays
Christmas holidays it doesn't matter my
biggest complaint last week I had with
my the parent-teacher conference that we
did with our kids my oldest son Patrick
he's 10 years old right now
I said so what what things can we work
on with my son and the teacher said have
one challenge with your son if you can
help me out with this I said what's that
I can't get your son to stop reading and
he doesn't pay attention to me and I
said I'm sorry ma'am I can't help you
with that I'm not going to tell my kid
to stop reading half the battle is
getting your kids to read so you got to
read 20 Pages the moment you turn six
you have to move your body whether you
like it or not you have to move your
body there's certain things that we do
as a family but those are the
expectations it's not it's not fair to
the average kid most other families come
over and like oh can I play you here
come play with my iPad I said he can
play on his iPad you don't have
permission to put on the iPad because
you haven't read yet you got to go read
your 20 pages but that nope he knows so
they go read and a parent's ask so how
can you do this all this other stuff if
I don't do it now it'll be 10 times
harder so yeah with boys we need to
figure out a way to toughen up boys and
if there's any way to do it military is
one way that certainly works for a lot
successful in Joe's talking about not
giving their children an easy life and I
think actually an easy life is probably
one of the reasons why the world has
become so soft
um so I think I think that's fascinating
what I have noticed right now is that if
you go on Instagram and you look at
every every person's bio it says
entrepreneur everybody now is an
entrepreneur in 2022. so what what is an
entrepreneur in 2022 what does that look
like well I mean you know the the
difference between a business owner and
an entrepreneur right so
um recently we've been looking at buying
a big business magazine so we're talking
to everybody about buying a business
magazine we'll have these calls and
we're making an offer on two of them
whether we'll buy it or not we don't
know maybe we'll buy it you're two years
from now but the process is not an easy
process when you're buying the platform
but you learn a lot about the evolution
of business owner versus entrepreneur a
business owner on one business had a few
employees made their money and that's it
maybe own a big business you got 500
employees a thousand employees but it's
one business you're running and
entrepreneur is a little bit of a few
different things you do uh I would tell
you myself I was first a business owner
uh if we really look at the definitions
even though my bio says entrepreneurs
and 10 years old because even at 10
years I was making money many different
ways days so it was all about the
multiple streams of income which I don't
believe in I believe multiple streams of
income should come way later on so for
me uh I'm doing the entrepreneur stuff
and I'm making money from seven
different places but seven different
places adds up to 20 grand a month 15
grand a month 10 grand it's not a lot of
money finally I'm not doing this anymore
I said listen moving forward I'm only
doing one thing and that's insurance and
that's it I'm not doing nothing else I
don't want to sell stocks I don't want
to sell bonds I don't want to do
mortgages I don't want to do real estate
I don't want to do Futures I don't want
to do Commodities I have the license to
sell most of the I don't want to do
mutual funds I just want to specialize
in insurance right because I read this
book Blue Ocean strategy fascinating
book if you haven't read it yet he the
author explains how in order to have a
blue ocean most people are competing in
a red ocean red ocean is a bunch of
sharks stealing from each other so
they're biting biting so they're all
bleeding where you should leave that
ocean and go to Blue Ocean and get a
market and no one's in so Yellow Tail
instead of competing with wine drinkers
yellowtail said no we're going to go
compete with beer because no wine
company is competing with beer boom they
take off so I said no we're gonna go and
just do insurance and we're going to
Target at that time the average agent
was a 56 year old white male
only 17 percent of Agents were women and
the Hispanic Community nobody was
touching them in the insurance industry
I said our blue ocean is to go where
people are now going I saw everybody
wanted to be a girl boss you know for
every dollar spent 75 cents the
decisions made by a woman so I'm looking
at these stats I'm like okay then I saw
Ron Paul raised six million dollars in
24 hours on MySpace running for office I
said 69 year old man raises six million
dollars on MySpace and 24. incredible so
social media wasn't yet a thing because
in the financial industry it was a lot
of Regulation so I said we're going to
go Target insurance so today 54 of our
agents are women the insurance company
that I rent that we just sold uh the 51
percent are Hispanic the average agent
is a 34 year old Hispanic female social
media Galore and the agency Grew From 66
agents to 37 000 agents today that we've
licensed because we went after one thing
so entrepreneur is after you make your
money then maybe you got five six seven
eight different things going on but I'm
willing to tell you if you want to make
the real money first just focus on being
a business owner first then when you
make your 10 million then go on trying
to be an entree again a lot of people
don't agree with me but that's my
philosophy that's interesting because I
like the idea of having multiple streams
of income because I'm terrified of not
having an income basically I think the
idea of relying on one centralized
individual or place or whatever just
terrifies me so is there a number a
month that you would say okay that's if
you're making that then you can have
multiple streams of income yeah so I
think for for me is how big is your
vision period because okay let's process
this guy Elon right PayPal what's he
sell it for they sell it for 1.5 billion
of the 1.5 billion they sold it for his
net was 180. of the 180 he got you know
which company he put the most money in
which one do you know this one I don't
is it it's pretty interesting because I
thought it's going to be the other one
added a 180. he put a hundred million
into SpaceX 70 in Tesla and 10 he put
into the Solar Company or something no
no into the boring company or Solar
Company but the most money he put into
SpaceX 70 Tesla in the 10 goes elsewhere
right so the Solar Company today if you
look at the valuation I want to say it's
a 24 billion dollar company I may be
wrong 25 billion dollar company give or
take Tesla's valuation one two trillion
I think today it's at around 680 700
billion dollars right the solar thing or
whatever else he's got going on now he
spends 50 or 44 billion to buy you know
Twitter which I believe he'll turn into
a trillion dollar company have my
specific reasons why I believe he can do
that if you look at that case study the
difference between a Bezos and a musk
they both want to go create you know go
into space and all that other stuff
right who do you think is doing it to
add to their resumes and who do you
think is doing it because they truly
want to go find out what the hell is
going on in space Elon Musk is doing it
because since he was a kid he read that
one book Galaxy you know so to him it's
like man I've always been enamored with
space Bezos was like nope I'm gonna get
there it's like a resume checklist like
Russell Brand you know what's his name
um uh uh uh the guy from Virgin uh uh
Richard Branson Richard Branson right so
he's kind of like I'm gonna go as well
but it's different reasons elon's not
going to space because he wants to say I
got there before you did he's truly
trying to figure out what's going on so
again multiple streams of income what's
your vision my vision was a completely
different Vision because my concern was
how people are controlling the narrative
by owning a lot of different media
platforms and so like Forbes do you know
Forbes uh was bought by a Chinese
company do you know Forbes that was
originally the founder Forbes his son
took it to the next level incredible
story what his son did but then uh the
next guy took it over uh whoever's
running it right now
Steve Forbes I want to say he eventually
sold it to a China company that owns 95
percent of Forbes today do you know who
they announced the international woman
of the year was last year in 2021 I
actually did a wonderful woman named
Hillary Clinton oh she's the woman can
you imagine Forbes where the guy who ran
Forbes the plane was called capitalists
tool that he would travel everywhere he
put a birthday party together on his
70th birthday party he invited everybody
he was best friends with Elizabeth
Taylor I think six 700 people showed up
to his birthday you know what he gave to
everybody on his birthday a Rolex watch
to every guest okay so this guy was like
the voice for capitalism who buys Forbes
95 of China so for me the vision of why
we're making money is to be able to
control the narrative we're capitalist
is still the hero so if you're going
back to your
you can't imagine having only one stream
of income it all depends on Division if
you're trying to build to sell to get a
lot of money then to have a lot of
different things well that's a different
Vision than somebody that's trying to
have it today media controlling the
narrative is um a really hot topic you
mentioned Elon Musk so let's get into it
why do you think Elon Musk is going to
turn Twitter into a trillion dollar
company uh okay so let's go through a
few different things number one I think
Tick Tock is going to be banned in the
next two to four years I think Patrick
is actually right tick tock is
definitely going to get banned in the
next two to four years probably by the
United States and when that happens the
rest of the world like the United
Kingdom is definitely gonna follow
that's why I want to take a moment to
talk to you about Tommy Dao it's an
alternative internet built by the people
for the people completely decentralized
which cannot be shut down by governments
you guys know that I'm a huge Free
Speech Advocate even if you think Tick
Tock or whatever the speech is is
potentially harmful I stand by free
speech I think it's imperative to any
functioning Civil Society and also to
find out truth we need free speech this
is why I believe in Tommy providing the
world with a new decentralized
alternative internet if you'd like more
information then I'm going to leave the
link for you in the description below
now let's get back to finding out why
Patrick thinks Tick Tock is going to be
banned and why more censorship is coming
a president is going to ban Tick-Tock
and that's going to happen in no time
when they do there's going to be a major
uproar Biden would never do it but I
think a Republican president will ban
Tick-Tock tick tock's already been by uh
um India who banned 100 different apps
and the next president will do it who's
on the Republican side if a Joe Rogan
who's known as a Centrist is saying the
Red Wave is coming like The Shining
elevator opening up and he is not a fan
of tick tock just in the next few years
tick tock's going to be banned when that
happens that's a lot of users that have
to find a home and they're not going to
go to Facebook because Facebook has
totally screwed it up they lost
valuation of uh this year alone when I
yeah I don't know if you know how much
they lost this year in valuation he lost
100 billion dollars of net worth but
Facebook's valuation has dropped 800
billion dollars insane on how much
valuation that is so why did they lose
that kind of valuation he's not trusted
unfortunately it's going to hurt him
obviously Facebook's not trusted they're
you know throttling Instagram on who
gets to see your post they do it with
Facebook as well so the audience from
there it's not like Tick Tock audience
is going to go to Instagram some of it
will but they're going to go to Twitter
number two I think elon's going to turn
Twitter into the next WeChat if you're
familiar with WeChat in China WeChat is
one app that does it all you know you
can do Uber Lyft uh food you know
content creation texting WhatsApp
everything under one app is WeChat
WeChat has around 900 million users it's
a trillion auto company I think Elon
will do that here next thing I think
Elon will do is Elon will figure out
with this Eight dollar a month
memberships that he's doing that people
are complaining about but I think he's
gonna have a 29.99 99.99 199 and we're
going to pay for it because LinkedIn as
much as people [__] about it linkedin's
lowest one is 99 and it goes all the way
up to 100 29.99 no one's ever complained
about LinkedIn you got to figure out a
way to make money he'll do that he's
going to create the app
to allow content creators to come to
make money so he's going to have a form
of a YouTube on Twitter which by the way
when he does that it's going to be quite
scary when he does that next one he's
bringing his Engineers from Tesla he
brought 50 Engineers from test land to
look at the technology so he's gonna
make the technology better in Twitter
and that's a no-brainer when he brings
Tesla's Engineers he brought Tesla's
head of HR they're going to hire the
best of the best to clean house with
Twitter obviously half the company is
getting laid off and he'll bring the
right people and I think he's going to
probably leave California move the
headquarters to most likely Austin or
Florida I don't think he'll stay there
and then the freedom of you know freedom
of speech type of people who feel
comfortable right now talking no one's
feeling uncomfortable talking on Twitter
yeah you're pretty comfortable I mean
yesterday somebody got uh the platform
was suspended I don't know if you saw
that with cat Kathy which she did but
she was impersonating Kim so she's
trying to troll he's like nope you're
off if you choose to adjust you can come
back and then at the end the day why I
think it'll be a trillion out of
companies because the guy that's running
it Elon um I believe he's gonna I try to
get some money to get into the company
Kathy Wood from Arc uh was able to get
some investment into Twitter but if you
invest with ARC today uh per dollar you
put only 12 cents goes into the Twitter
stock so we're trying to figure out a
way to get into the Twitter although
it's very very hard Morgan Stanley's not
doing it Goldman's not doing it but I'm
just a big believer what's going to
happen by the way I could be completely
wrong and it completely flops and it
does nothing and I'm comfortable with
that but if I'm a betting man I would
bet on Twitter being a trillion Auto
Company my only issue with Elon Musk
evolving the company turning into some
kind of WeChat like you said is that it
would almost become unusable and
saturated a bit like Facebook Facebook
they tried to do that I know obviously
there are other reasons why Mark
Zuckerberg failed but
I feel like it might become saturated
difficult to use and I think one of the
reasons Twitter was so successful is
because it just remained one thing yeah
do you not think it could potentially
become unusable let me ask you a
question when's the last time you
tweeted a complaint or a concern at Mark
Zuckerberg and he responded back never
well I don't think he's on Twitter
actually but the point is just never
period right but when's the last time
you hear a number of stories where Elon
responds back wanting feedback and ideas
on how to make it better that's the
difference this is this is not a regular
guy Elon is a guy that knows what he
wants but I also believe elon's a guy
that's a what do you think like hey
audience what do you think should I
bring Vine back what do you think uh to
make Twitter the next app and then Mr
Beast says whatever you do don't do what
anybody else can duplicate and copy so
this is what do you think guy with his
own identity and signature to the
product it's a different operator very
very different this is not just a very
very smart guy this is a very very very
smart guy that understands she still
needs you that's the difference so some
of these guys are like ah you're going
to do it no matter what whether you like
it or not I don't think that's enough
yeah that's a great Point yeah I see I'm
replying to people all the time on
Twitter so yeah and that's a great place
where 300 billion dollars we're playing
this person will be like who do you
think you know do you know who I am why
would I respond it's like no okay cool
yeah it's amazing it's a different guy
it's amazing I want to just focus a
little bit more on entrepreneurship I
want to understand why or if you do
think entrepreneurship is so important
and also the world has changed a lot in
the last 20 years so would you say that
being an entrepreneur now is far more
important than it was 20 30 years ago a
year uh do I think it's more important
now than 20 30 years ago I don't know if
I could say more important or less
important I think it was definitely more
important 200 years ago 100 years ago
because they needed to really set the
tone and get it going uh what I do think
is happening today as well as in
entrepreneurs are becoming just as
valuable as entrepreneurs the only
difference between an entrepreneur and
an entrepreneur is the one guy put up
the money and risked it and the other
guy didn't aside from that the
entrepreneur still works as hard still
as obsessed about the company 24 7 is
still wanting to grow the company owns a
piece of the company a Steve Balmer
who's a 100 billion dollar guy he's an
entrepreneur a Tim Cook is an
entrepreneur Steve Jobs on the second
time around when he came back he was an
entrepreneur so I think uh the pressures
of having to like I I would love to see
Twitter profiles and Instagram profiles
changing to saying entrepreneur just as
much as we see entrepreneur because
companies that are creating an
environment of Entrepreneurship are able
to stay Innovative and trendy where
companies that are just here's how we do
it you better do this and they're not
going to produce entrepreneurs but going
back to answer your question for you on
the entrepreneur side I think
markets need entrepreneurs I think a
Detroit today needs to figure out a way
to get rid of all the politicians and
bring the entrepreneurs in I think a New
York needs to eliminate as much politics
that they have and remember this city
became the financial capital of the
world because of entrepreneurs let's get
back to that if I was a governor of a
country of a state or if I was a
president of a country I would I would
make a very big investment and focus and
emphasis on recognizing the
entrepreneurs the job creators and then
seeing what area doesn't have enough of
them and giving incentives to go into
those communities like we're in Fort
Lauderdale right do you think there's
more entrepreneurs in Fort Lauderdale or
Miami right now I'm going to guess Miami
you're right it is Miami and look what's
happening to Miami right so yeah if I'm
running Fort Lauderdale I'm finding out
a creative way to bring people here you
know if I'm more on the inside I'm going
to try to bring people in from Orlando
but some markets needed more than others
and some countries needed more than
others but I think you need both
entrepreneurs and entrepreneurs today
do you think
quoting yourself entrepreneurs when
they're entrepreneurs or Freelancers
these days do you think that the term
entrepreneurs sort of lost its true
meaning but you know here's here's how
it also looks okay you ever met people
that think they're very good looking but
they're not yes okay you ever met a girl
that thinks she's so super attractive
but she's not probably okay Annie you
ever met a girl who is super attractive
but she doesn't know she's attractive of
course and have you ever met a guy
that's extremely handsome but he's like
not confident about himself right so how
do you tell them apart right the way you
tell it apart is by what the market
calls you you can go to a local business
Place get a DBA and create a business
card call yourself CEO but if you're the
only person that calls you a CEO you're
not a CEO right yeah if hundreds of
other people call you their CEO you're a
true CEO you can call yourself an
entrepreneur but if nobody in a
Marketplace sees you as an entrepreneur
you're a delusional man it's okay A lot
of people are you know a lot of people
think they're sexy but they're not and
that's okay if you think you're sexy
more power to you some people think they
have to take care of their health some
people think they have to exercise
there's certain people that think no I'm
300 pounds and I'm sexy I don't think
I'm sexy when I'm 300 pounds I remember
when I hit 257 pounds and I look at my
wife I said babe what is up with that
belly of mine I'm looking at the mirror
I said that's nasty oh my God what the
hell happened I'm always 240. I got 17
pounds I got to figure something out so
then you lose the weight because to me
257 doesn't look right so typically the
guys that are true entrepreneurs or
doers or entrepreneurs their level of
expectation of themselves is so much
higher than those that they're not did
you see the recent movie by Elvis pres
the Elvis movie I actually didn't watch
it but I heard it oh my God so the guy's
name is Austin Butler Austin's Austin
Butler right if you've not seen the
movie do yourself a favor go first watch
his interview with Jimmy Kimmel I
watched the interview my brother told me
to watch it together you watched a guy
and he says uh you know I mean you know
I'm more like the guy that just you know
I struggle with not being good enough
and you know I feel like I'm not there
yet and you know I got work to do and
I'm here in Elvis's house and that's
what I'm dealing with and you're like I
believe him I don't think he's being
fake like he's being authentic I watched
a movie twice in the first week because
I just believed this guy right and my
kids watched it we want we watched the
interview together there's there's a
certain weird insecurity in the people
that constantly get better and improve
they don't think they're there yet or
good enough yet so if you automatically
want to call yourself an entrepreneur or
whatever
and you haven't really ran a business
maybe it makes you feel better totally
fine I understand the whole concept what
is the concept from uh that one movie uh
JT Marlin what is that movie with the
stock Brokers the fake stock Brokers
yeah but what's the movie's name a
boiler room right the fake it till you
make it right I understand there's a
place for fake it till you make it but
you better make it you know what I'm
saying if you're gonna fake it till you
never make it it's like people are
burned out of you talking about you're
going to be there one day but you can
fake it for a minute but you better
eventually make it I've heard that
before and I think it's fascinating the
idea that entrepreneurs are people who
have such high expectations for
themselves and nothing is good enough
and that's what keeps them going is that
what keeps you going
yeah for me it's a vision so it's a few
different things one I have a side like
right now where I'm eating at my at the
lunch restaurant I go to and the guy
next to me says hey Pat can we do
something to come he's a guy that
follows the content I said she wants to
do book signing so he starts saying do
you know I've collected baseball cards I
have every baseball players autographed
since 1946. I said what he says every
player that's ever placed in played in
baseball Major Leagues I have their
autograph I said since 1940s he says how
many players are there 13 000. wow and
then he says I heard you're also into
cars I said you know what's so crazy I
thought I was into cars I don't like
cars I have a truck parked outside every
day I drive a truck okay F-150 it's a
Shelby it's nice but that's what I do
last three years that's all I drive the
other night we're going to uh Mario just
recently got engaged and we're going to
Casa D'Angelo for dinner I tell Jen Jen
let's take the Ferrari out no babe my
skirt and I would much I'm like ah let's
just take the we took one of the SUVs or
whatever we went there but I tell you if
I look at a base baseball card I'm 12
years old if I hold one of the cards
you're going to be like this guy's not
44. he's childlike
business to me I feel that way when I'm
playing business I feel like I'm 12
years old I feel like we're playing a
game and it's a freaking blast when
we're playing this game right the other
part of it is vision and the other part
of it is my uh one of our relatives
insulted my dad when I was 25 years old
at a Christmas party and he did it right
in front of me and I made a promise to
my dad that I'm going to keep till the
day I die I say the world is going to
know your last name and I was a nobody
at that time I'm a regular 25 year old
I'm making maybe six figures no one
knows who I am I've never produced the
content ever produced the video I've
never done nothing like that but I said
the World's Gonna know your last name
and you're going to be very proud that
you sacrifice everything to bring us to
U.S you're going to see what I'm going
to do I'm hopefully you're going to be
alive to see all this stuff and
obviously he's getting a glimpse of it
right now so game long-term vision and
Pops is the reason why I love this game
that's beautiful I like that a lot if
you had to start all over again from the
beginning and build your wealth up which
industry would you say is the most
lucrative would you get into
um Finance banking crypto content
creation real estate where would you
start such a great question my answer is
a different question my answer is I
don't care about the industry
I want to I want to work with a killer
it's who I want to work with I want to
work with somebody that is absolutely
non-stop obsessed very good at what I
don't give that guy's in real estate if
it's an insurance if it's in crypto if
it's in pharmaceutical sales I don't
care if it's in technology coding don't
care if you're the best and you're the
only one to have access to getting
closer to working with I want to learn
your habits I want to learn your
day-to-day I want to learn your
obsession I want to learn how you
negotiate Beyond closed doors there is
this camera that people are watching
right now with our interview run but
they haven't seen how I negotiate when
I'm doing negotiations on the call or
resume with other people so they don't
know how that works versus when you're
in the room and you're seeing how
uncomfortable it gets at one point and
your three of my guys sitting there and
then you six years later you're
negotiating that way the value of that
is not let me do a course and teach you
how to negotiate if I'm able to work
with somebody in any industry I am very
much open to any industry if I'm 21
years old coming out I'm going to work
but anybody as long as that person is a
killer
I want to talk about the negotiation and
how uncomfortable that can be because I
know how uncomfortable that can be and I
so I actually don't like to do it I have
men that do that because it's just it's
just better for me but talk to you about
why that's uncomfortable how do you deal
with that level of Confrontation and how
do you also walk away from a deal
because you're just not happy with
what's on the table it's so much fun I
mean I find it so uncomfortable it would
be like to me a good debate a good cut
the other day we had a guy on the
podcast Antonio Brown who uh uh uh the
most uncomfortable podcasts we've ever
done who just called words everything
you an idiot you don't know what you're
talking about you're acting like a girl
like this and at one point at the
podcast sitting there saying huh okay
what are we gonna do here right now I
really don't need to be here this guy is
very difficult but let's see if we can
break through this year so that
additional let me take a different angle
on the way I'm going to communicate with
them and see where we can go and in the
conversation one two I heard you like to
swim yeah I like to swim I said
how early do you swim in the morning to
say no how old were you when you first
started swimming I was a kid why do you
like swimming so because when you're
underwater you don't hear anything
interesting I love that okay so that's
like a concept of bike motorcycle when
you're out there motorcycle you don't
hear anything it's like you're in a
certain mode right I said so tell me
about this and then we went into Brady
and then he made a comment about Brady
and what he does so Brady had your back
why'd you do this and then that video
was went viral all over the media
they're writing about it but that is a
form of negotiation in an interview
where it gets uncomfortable and if you
take the right turn it's about to be a
very interesting interview versus oh my
God I made them upset it's uncomfortable
let me back down so in negotiation
you're going to hear that you're going
to hit that wall as well we're at one
point one party or both parties are
going to be uncomfortable and whoever
cannot
whoever cannot handle it in that moment
uh and by the way here's the other part
I used to be the one where negotiating
was about 100 me winning and the other
person losing and then I noticed as a 20
year old people weren't coming back to
want to keep doing business with me so
that's not the right way either you have
to do it in a way where you're making
money they're making money someone's
always going to get a little bit of a
better better deal right you know and
it's always like MCI I think it was MCI
and atnt or somebody like them when
somebody bought atnt and the company
that bought a TNT they they were bigger
so at T is like well we're not okay with
you buying us why not it says because of
our name he says of course if we buy you
we're going to use your name not ours
so to ATT that's a win because they
wanted to keep the name a TNT to the
other companies like we don't care what
the name is we're bigger we want to buy
you we'll let the company so imagine
like actually let's process this as a
bigger company imagine let's pick a name
Ford motor company buys give me a small
car company whatever small car company
and Ford is willing to change the
company's name to the other car company
even though that's kind of what happens
so in negotiation ATT still felt like
day one because a legacy the name so but
it's a game it's a beautiful game and if
you do it right more people want to
negotiate with you I was 31 years old
sitting there negotiating with a guy
named Harry okay not going to tell you
the full name but he's probably gonna
for years about this so we were sitting
there he says Pat I'm afraid to do
business with you I said tell me why
he's a Wharton business school guy I
love this guy spent time with him and
his wife and he wanted to invest and I
said uh listen this is the percentage
that I'm willing to do at this
investment he says you know it's it's
midnight we're at my office we've been
talking for five hours he says you know
I'm afraid to negotiate with you he says
what he says because I'm afraid you're
going to get the better deal and not me
I said let's just say that's the truth
but let me kind of give you something
else for you to be thinking about I said
let's say that does happen wouldn't you
want your running mate to be a
ridiculous negotiator if you and I are
Partners together he says I would I said
if you come in with this with this
investment I'm officially going to
negotiate the deals for the rest of your
life why don't we do this together you
know what he does he doesn't do the deal
oh he doesn't doesn't do the deal why
not you know how much it costs them you
know what his investment would have made
him 40 times this investment would have
made him wow 40 times he knows it why
wasn't he convinced because he still
thought I was getting the better deal
right he had he had a hard time with him
by the way you know how much it cost me
for not doing that deal
he helped me maybe he made more money
I don't know 25 million 40 million bucks
oh my God just by him saying no so I
appreciate you thank you so much man for
not wanting to take that offer that's
amazing what a sweetheart of a guy no
absolutely it's like a major shout out
to Harry great guy
very thankful for Harry he's actually a
really good guy good family guy but yeah
cost himself 40 million but no good in
business
but he's afraid he's afraid okay go to
take some risks you do sometimes by the
way you know I don't blame him because
at that time I was not yet proven I was
only proven to be a great sales leader
right and a great salesperson I'd never
run a company I'd never exited a company
so his re his risk was valid that he had
that concern but I also knew I was going
places it makes a lot of sense um okay I
want to talk about the world that we're
living in right now because like I said
at the beginning there's a lot of
strange things happening we saw
lockdowns medical coercions mandates
inflation's at a 40-year high nobody
seems to know what a woman is these days
so I want to get your take on what you
think the hell is going on right now
what I love about this week nobody knows
what a woman is so here's here's how how
awesome this is you know why I like to
interview Communists I think I am we've
interviewed more Communists on
valuetainment than any other channel on
YouTube and the reason for it is the
following
the key with a communist or a socialist
is to let them talk
um
the more a socialist talks the more
communist talks eventually you know what
happens there's flaws in their argument
it doesn't work so so let's just say
this whole thing with women right
the question is asked so what's a woman
oh why are you asking me a question like
that I'm not a biologist to answer that
question you don't need to be a
biologist know what a woman is right
yeah but I'm just not in that space so
just ask me a different question but
what is a woman if you think you're a
woman you're a woman oh really yeah okay
cool no problem four weeks later that
same person is arguing for women's
rights you can't do that now so so but
what happens all of a sudden is they get
stuck and they're like oh my God now
what do I say what just happened is your
BS got exposed that's a beautiful thing
when you and I don't have an argument
okay and you try to keep selling your
point the more you talk if you truly
have an argument then it's I'm gonna be
like you know what she's got a good
point but if it's BS the more you talk
then there's going to be leaks and
forget about me seeing the leaks in your
argument you're gonna see the leaks in
your argument now you're gonna like oh
let me change the subject and deflect or
go a different place we've all done this
I've done it as a kid you do it as an
adult you do it as a you're going to go
through this naturally the biggest thing
about today is bad ideas don't work bad
policy have consequences ludicrous ideas
eventually get exposed and people are
not naive or dumb for the small
percentage that wants to protect their
egos and follow through on their parents
politics whatever their parents politics
were some people will never be
Republicans because their dad cheated on
their mom and you will never ever get
them to be a republican because to
become a republican means you're saying
your dad was okay for what he did some
kids will never become Democrats or
republican because of upbringing some
people won't become because it was a
rich person in the family that left you
and you didn't spend a lot of time with
them so to everybody you see in your
life you see it as that I was 14 years
old the first time politics was
something that I was having to think
about because our Miss Luz our teacher
was talking about it so I come up and I
said Mom are we Democrats or are we
Republicans and she says uh yeah we're
Democrats I said why are we Democrats
and she says we're Democrats because
Democrats are for the poor and
Republicans are for the rich
I said you know when I grow up one day I
want to be a Republican and I have no
clue what a republican is all I meant to
say is as a kid is I want to be rich one
day I'm a registered independent today
center right politically full capitalist
when it comes on to economy uh but I
think they're losing because their
arguments make zero sense long term
but why are we at this point where these
policies and arguments although they
make zero sense are actually being
implemented and rolled out um Across
America but also across the world
because Americanization is very powerful
and very real the moment you're within a
click
most people feel the obligation to agree
with anybody on your Clique says right
and it's very hard to disagree with
people in your own Clique so parents
your dad believes in something it's hard
to say I don't know if I believe mom
says I don't know if I believe that
right okay all right so if you're you're
a you've always voted Democrat okay and
the Democrats say well here's a trans
this
you look around you're like
oh okay I got 19 other Democrats I
respect are saying this yeah so here's
what and you're like but I don't believe
that
okay that was kind of weird I don't but
okay that's not a big deal let's let
this one go it's not going to be a big
deal and then they say but but let me
also tell you this and here's why if you
don't take this you're not being
responsible and you're somebody that's
maybe a freedom of choice when it comes
down to you know abortion of pro-life or
pro-choice you're pro-choice and you're
like why am I forcing this person to
take what they don't want to take isn't
that pro-choice but everybody on my side
is saying yeah okay yeah you got to take
it if you don't you don't care about my
health because you're putting my life in
jeopardy you're irresponsible and then
you go home and you're like that doesn't
make any sense though right so some
unfortunately will blindly vote for
anything that their side says very few
people will question and those who
question eventually will get closer to
the truth and those who don't
will be a pond that that party is going
to use until you eventually can't think
for yourself
yeah there's a lot of Pawns right now
and I think there's a lot of people who
over the last two years knew that things
weren't right but quietly had to just go
along with it because their you know
identity politics you're a woman you're
an immigrant you have to you know think
certain things but there's other strange
things going on like unelected Elites at
the world economic Forum talking about
climate change digital IDs um these are
the same people that set the covert
narrative there's Bill Gates buying up
Farmland the world the world economic
Forum even said that by 2030 you owe
nothing you'll be happy and you'll eat
bugs so my question to you is what do
you think the purpose is behind all of
this and do you want to eat bugs and owe
nothing and do you think you'll be happy
so you know I'm assuming if I were to
come into your office right behind your
desk if I'm a Banning man I'm willing to
bet there's probably a nice poster or
painting of Klaus Schwab right behind
your oh absolutely it's actually above
my bed it's actually above my bed
there's this this painting of this guy
but again going back to it here's what
I'll say to you so this is a completely
different view that I have of this so
say you go to a party okay and you're
sitting there and there's a punk who's a
bully but he doesn't know who you are
and he's bullying everybody okay pushing
people around making fun of them in a
weird way like in stuff like there's a
difference between being sarcastic and a
bully he's being a dick he's being an
[__] he's being a true bully right
how long will you let it go see this is
not really your element in your
environment you're just somebody that
was invited maybe you let it go for 10
minutes you're like yeah it's not it's
his house I'm not going to say nothing
20 minutes 30 minutes an hour he's still
going drinks gets worse gets worse gets
worse and then he comes to you and then
you're eventually going to be like yeah
no we're not doing this very simple okay
we're not doing this you know everybody
has a limit some people are a little bit
more tolerant than others are this whole
concept of what they're pushing there
are a lot of people that will buy into
that they will owe nothing and be happy
and now you see the message of
minimalism and it's going to be okay and
yesterday we're at church and the
pastor's up on stage and talking about
who cares about living in a 6 000 square
foot house I know people that are 10
times more happy or living in a shack
studio with five kids and they're okay
life is not about this life is not about
that and you know what's crazy I'm
looking around the place I'm like this
is a 200 million dollar facility who
gave this money to you where did this
money come from didn't you do like a
campaign to raise 200 million bucks so
who are you talking to who's your
audience like who do you think you lose
when you talk like that to congregation
you think your person that's sitting at
this church that maybe is willing to
give you 10 million bucks 5 million
bucks is saying absolutely let me give
it to this or do you think that person
takes and says maybe you don't value
somebody like me part of your church I
get the whole concept about you know a
poor man has more likely of going into
heaven than the rich man and I totally
understand I've heard that story million
we've all heard the story before but
messaging matters
in whatever message you have one time I
was asking my guys let's say we have an
audience of 100 people and you're up
here trying to sell stocks mutual funds
and bonds hypothetically we have 10
different of you that give presentations
to this hundred people they're all
qualified buyers but you got 10
different different presenters that give
a presentation to these other buyers
will the same amount of buyers buy from
all of you and everyone's like
no
perfect tell me why like oh
I don't know I want you to actually
think about this so maybe the person
that said yes to you said no to me why
did they say no to me but they say yes
to you and they invested two million
dollars with you why did they say no to
me everything's about messaging
messaging will attract victims if
everybody around you is a crap magnet
it's because of your messaging you're a
crap magnet if everybody around you is
somebody that's going after and wanting
to do something big with their lives
it's a reflection of your messaging if
everybody in your political party are
the ones that are always complaining
whining that's what you're selling if
everybody in your political party is
independent doing things that's part of
messaging as well so maybe we need to
take inventory and realize this
messaging by Klaus Schwab or the world
economic Forum that they're going out
they're saying what they're saying their
messaging is maybe going to work for the
first six months 12 months maybe five
years maybe 10 years then all of a
sudden there's going to be an eruption
of people that are going to get up and
say wait wait those who specialize in
bullying the bully and he's going to
realize do these people I can't bully I
can control these masses I can't control
these 28 people and these 28 people are
way more powerful than these 20 2.8
billion people all it takes is 2.28
people that specialize in bullying the
bully to get up and say Klaus knock it
off you've lost your mind no people
don't feel that way and the other 2.0
2.18 billion they're going to be like
what the hell was I thinking about don't
worry you're not alone a lot of people
fell for it they have no clue what
they're doing you want to be free trust
me you have your own individual dreams
this right here is only mine you have
yours he has his yeses this is my
signature this is your signature we all
have dreams some big some small we all
have them to say you're going to take
away my ability to fight for my dreams
where the hell is my identity how do I
leave my Mark here not your mark not his
mark my mark Klaus has left his Mark how
about the rest of the people it's it's
an idea that's going to get exposed and
people are going to wake up when they're
gonna say this guy's lost his mind they
have no clue what they're talking about
it's going to happen it's really
optimistic I'm somewhat a little bit
more cynical I get it I feel like
tyranny happens gradually and I feel
like power and money corrupts so I don't
know if those 28 people are really gonna
what's gonna happen with those 28 people
wherever those 28 people go eventually
the two point 8 billion people will go
meaning so I I lived in Iran okay say
Khomeini doesn't show up to Iran Say
Jimmy Carter helps to Shah and Kissinger
they kept their promises and the Shah
got help from U.S and there is no
Revolution Khomeini doesn't go to Iran
what happens those three thousand
political prisoners are not let out and
9 11 doesn't take place right but Iran
lost many of us but many of us came to
the states we went to Australia we went
here we went different places we're
gonna go contribute to the next Society
the types of cloud swap that do what
they do they're eventually going to deal
with people like us we're not going away
the Market's filled with people that are
Fighters you think Elon Musk 10 years
ago had any plans of buying Twitter like
you think that was part of his game plan
how much you think that increased during
covet how much you think the silencing
increased in covet you think his plan on
his business plan was one day I want to
buy Twitter from my friend Jack Dorsey
no I don't see that being on his dream
list or a business plan I just see that
they pushed him so much he says don't
worry I'm here I'm going to buy this now
here's what I'd love to see if you
really want to see this guy make people
lose their minds I'd love to see Along
by CNN for six billion hours I'd like to
see it I'd love to see him buy CNN for a
second by the way that's all it's going
to cost by the way it's a six billion
dollar company right now in shambles he
can probably buy it for five billion
make the offer of seven billion dollars
buy it and go do what Ted Turner
originally wanted to do which is stories
from both sides go fulfill that guy's
prophecy not the mess they have created
us CNN today so but guys like that 6
billion is not a lot of money people
need to see what musk did other
billionaires who have that kind of money
to say okay if musk bought that what am
I going to buy what are you going to buy
and maybe for you you know you may be
like well I don't have billions well how
can you contribute you're doing that
right now with your channel you're
getting people to think people know who
you are you've created a platform you're
getting people to start questioning
themselves and you're from London yeah
so the audience that you're bringing is
a different audience but I think more
people are going to wake up and say just
this doesn't add up and that fight's
going to continue are some countries
going to take a fall and lose a decade
two three decades because they're buying
to show up 100 are those leaders still
going to rise up yes and everybody else
is going to follow those people every
time it does every time that happens so
these leaders predominantly tend to be
men and I think you know you know mask
is a perfect example and I think
there's a huge war on masculinity right
now I've personally watched the
feminization of men and I'm only in my
20s but I've seen it in the last 10
years
um and I know you've spoken a lot about
this with your five hour podcast with
Andrew Tate so why do you think they're
trying to feminize men do you think it
has something to do with not allowing
the likes of Elon Musk to rise up and
sort of put a stop to the Klaus Schwab
agenda
it could be you know it's
um look you know why I love capitalism
you know why socialists hate capitalism
think about it why do socialists hate
capitalism because it's freaking hard
yeah it's so hard to build a business
it's so difficult it's so annoying it
could cost you your marriage you're
gonna miss out on a lot of parties
you're going to miss out on a lot of
great memories you're gonna miss out as
a capitalist it's not easy they think
it's easy it's so incredibly hard elon's
most liked tweet it's got like six or
seven million likes he said so I work 16
hours a day for 360 days for 30 years or
whatever he puts and people still call
me lucky right you know no he's not
worth 300 billion dollars because the
guy got lucky did he get lucky
throughout the process of course he did
but this thing is hard so you know we
have a hard time looking at people and
saying I can never be like you and
that's okay I can never be LeBron James
as a basketball player never I can't
jump 46 inches I I don't have that
vertical ability I don't have it right
there's a lot of things we can't do and
that's fine there's certain things
LeBron cannot do that I can do he just
can't do what things I can do and that's
fine right there's certain things you
can't to do that I can do you have to be
okay with that but there are certain
things I can't do that you can do and
I'm certainly very okay with that when
it becomes about you saying no I want to
be able to do we're equal in every
aspect of life you're full of yourself
you're naive and not only are you naive
you're incredibly arrogant to think that
feminists are probably some of the most
arrogant people you'll ever meet as
weird as this sounds they're not
tolerable they don't like to tolerate
anybody that disagrees with them they're
arrogant they think they know it all
they're annoying to be around they're
constant
I put an event together such a weird uh
thing happened at the Vault
um we're at the Vault conference and
first night I'm giving assignment for
people to go answer these questions so
the next day they come out and I said so
tell me what was your breakthrough you
had last night what decisions did you
make anybody's giving me theirs and then
all of a sudden one lady to my right
she's kind of like trying to put her
hand up but she's not and then she
finally puts I said you want to go so go
ahead tell us what was it for you so she
stands up she says you know what Patrick
uh I've been running a salon one of the
best I'm great at what I do all my
people make a lot of money we do very
very well and I've done very well for
myself and her sister sitting right next
to her but she says I make money I have
money
and I'm sitting here telling you
I want to get married no I want a man
yeah I want a family
and she gets emotional she says I no
longer want to compete against a man
I want a family
and the entire crowd
quiet
it's like she just said what like who
needs to hear that millions of people
need to hear that today right and you
see these 65 year old women videos going
viral where they say I walked with the
feminist I bought into the argument
being a feminist man was an enemy in my
life this lady says this is the most
touching lady she was not a good talk or
not she wasn't like she just regular
talking she said I'm 65 years old I've
never been married I have no kids I will
never be able to have kids I will never
be able to experience what it is to be
married to a man when I was in my 20s
the concept of feminism stole that away
from me
just because I looked at man as the
enemy and he's not
and a lot of people are going to go
through this and it's gonna suck because
this thing goes like this I'm 44 years
old right I look at my hands like this
like this I look 22. right I look young
like this but like this I'm 44 years old
okay this hand didn't look like this
when I was 22 years old I'm 44 I got
four kids at the house you know my dad's
80. I look at my dad when he walks right
now I'm like man you don't walk like
that before and I see his back and he's
walking like a and my son tries to mimic
out his grandpa walks it's funny but at
the same time you're like this guy's got
a hunch in his back this thing goes by
very very quickly if there's one thing
we cannot do is screw up the family
nucleus of what it's like because okay
let's just say you come home you're a
billionaire and you don't have kids that
lives past your life you don't have
somebody to share it with let's say
every night you sleep with somebody new
okay cool let's role play that every
night first night Mary second night
Jennifer third night Jackie fortnite
Cindy how many nights can you go like
that okay cool it's bragging rights
maybe for a year two years cool I've
been with this many
who the hell you having conversations
with like what do you think like for me
my high is
we work we go to dinner we sit down we
have an incredible conversation together
right
that is an incredible feeling with
friends same people preferably because
it's getting deeper and deeper a spouse
your kids your family that's emotional
that's why we live oh believe me it gets
me emotional as well you have no idea
how much I like yesterday I'm sitting
there watching Rocky 4 with my kids
and I said kids let me tell you
something I said what do you think about
this movie my tikon Dylan afterwards it
sounds like punch him punch him hit him
hit him hit him he's getting all into
he's getting animated and he says Dad
this is one of the best movies of all
time I said it's the best movie he says
no Pearl Harbor is the best movie but
this is the second best movie of all
time so we're sitting afterwards so tell
me what you took away from this movie
and they're telling what they're saying
I said you guys have to realize this I
said when I watch this movie I was seven
years old the first time I watched it I
was in Iran and my mom said they were
Communists my dad said they were
imperialist it was as if this movie was
about my mom and dad where they would
fight all the time and his message was
trying to figure out a way to see what
things we have in common but I said
everybody's a rocky we all got big
dreams don't ever let anybody steal that
dream away from you but I enjoy
relationships I enjoy all of that and
unfortunately this feminist movement is
hurting us having relationships and
knowing that I got strengths you don't
have you don't you have strengths I
don't have but what if we work together
we can do something big together again I
don't think it's sustainable but I do
think it's going to steal away a lot of
people's dreams unfortunately I think
that was uh no said really well I think
that um I'm blessed to know that
feminism is a scam like at this stage
I'm blessed because I totally agree with
you I think you do reach as a woman you
do reach an age and you know you're just
sort of like is that entirely satisfying
like is that what it's going to bring me
absolute happiness and you're sort of
not allowed to talk about that you know
there's a lot of shaming if you're a
stay-at-home mum but I agree with you I
think there's a massive war on the
family unit but it's but it's not just
feminism there's
the feminization of men
so they're trying to make men more
feminine so that women then have to rise
up to to fill that void and provide for
themselves
um so so how do we solve the
feminization of men so for some people
it's too late you can't do nothing about
it like you see right now Dwyane Wade's
ex-wife is suing him for forcing his son
to go through the you know trans you
know surgery before he's 18 years old
and they're going back and forth and
some are saying you know Dwayne's doing
it because he's choosing career because
he's about to get a big deal with Disney
versus this I think that kid is done I
think that kid's going to buy into what
Dwayne Gabriel Union or selling to him
he's unfortunately going to be in and
he's going to lose 10 20 years of his
life most likely that's the odds that
one's gone
uh I think the kids that are going to be
raised in parents whose uh you know Mom
Mom Dad that they're they're gonna be
they're gonna be it's gonna take them a
minute for them to find themselves you
know I I knew a guy that ended up
becoming a pastor who's a mom was a uh
was a lesbian and was also with a his
wife her wife so it was very confusing
for this guy took him till 35 years old
to kind of figure himself out still
loves mom and his both moms whatever the
relationship was but at the same time he
took uh figured out a way to figure
himself out I think uh believe it or not
in a weird way if I was a pastor today
our church would be jam-packed we would
have so many people today because
man I don't think churches know how to
tell their stories very well uh uh
forget about this is not even a
conversation about Jesus God Catholicism
Christianity seven-day Jehovah's you
know LDS I'm not doing a debate part
that's another discussion if we want to
have that kind of a debate that's not
for here
I I I would rather have my kids go to a
Jewish private school than go to a
public school because at least the
Jewish private schools going to teach
certain basic values and principles I'm
okay if my kids go to a Catholic Church
I'm okay if my Catholic school because I
just want some kind of values and
principles to be taught and I think for
kids today when they're alone and we're
not around because we're not going to be
around them all the time they need to
believe that someone some spirit is with
them that they're not alone I think they
need that today because it's a lot of
pressure today that parents cannot be
you know omnipresent in all these other
places you can your kids are with
somebody else for 10 hours out of the
day you're going to come home you've got
two hours with your kids per night then
you got the weekend you don't have that
many hours with your kids so
I think parents are going to need help I
would suggest parents to plug into a
church as quickly as possible find a
pastor you like an environment you like
and I'm not even pitching denomination
just go to plays if you're Jewish go
practice it if you're Christian go if
you're Catholic go practice it because
your kids are going to benefit from it
long term
um
in regards to uh men being men I I think
parents have to realize whoever you
present as a hero your kids will
duplicate and go after so if you present
somebody who is constantly a victim oh
my God life is hard as a hero your kid's
gonna aspire to be a victim because
that's how your kid gets attention if
the way your kid gets attention is by
being sick and you always go to them and
you baby them all the time when that kid
gets older that's how they're going to
get your attention because they're sick
because they're going to get babied by
you I think we need to let people fail a
little bit I think we need to let kids
go through a little bit of Challenge and
times I think putting kids in sports
with a coach that's pushing the kids
sports is very important somebody
kicking their butt is very important I
think boys having strong men around them
if a single mother is raising their kids
figure out a way to have that Uncle
that's tough to be around figure out a
way to have your brother you know
whoever it is to to be around those guys
because if you don't some people are
going to be lost there's no saving them
it's over for everybody else we want to
make movies where the hero is going to
be the capitalist the hero is going to
be strong men man's man that is in
someone's life and what happens when a
real man is in someone's life and how
that builds their character Hollywood's
your movies are going to matter your
videos are going to matter content is
going to matter books we write are going
to matter right now you know penguin
owns this company called who HQ my kids
read who HQ books we probably bought
five 600 qhq books and they're good
books but in there you will subtly see
messaging from the left that's in the
who HQ I think there needs to be a
competitor to that I think there needs
to be competitor to content this is a
very big task this is not easy it's
almost as if the people that these
subjects matter to the most need to hold
a one-week retreat at a place where they
come together and they say okay listen
we need a hundred billion dollars how
much are you putting to put in of your
money look I don't have a uh 10 billion
dollars to put in but I put in 10
million bucks
I'll put in a million bucks my influence
is more from the mic that I have I put
100 million bucks hey I'm going to bring
my file which one do you want to take
I'm going to go into the movie Set how
about yourself I'm gonna go start a
university what are you going to do I
think there needs to be that kind of a
meeting being held because it's and and
by the way I wouldn't be surprised if
that meeting is going to be held in the
next
two or three years where they're going
to be talking about these types of
things but I think the money people the
influential people need to come together
stand up be unified not be afraid and uh
go put their money where their mouth is
and kind of get to work but because if
they don't do that the other side is
very United when it comes on to this
topic so we need some of our power
players to come together and uh get to
work because this is a real issue that
needs the right attention oh I
absolutely invest you simply just invest
in a future of humanity but no I think
you're right and I think the older I get
the more I appreciate the value of
religion and the importance of it um but
I'm going to leave it there I want to
thank you so much for coming on it's
been such a pleasure learning from you I
think you offer so much value
um so just really briefly where can
people find valuetainment um if they
they want to come follow oh they can
find you can find it on YouTube they can
find it all over the place I will say
this we just launched a new app called
minute where on manect the reason why I
launches at minute is because uh years
ago a lawyer had a seven minute call
with a lawyer and charged me 30 minutes
for a seven minute Cod I like it I
called him I said we only had a seven
minute call and he said well seven
minutes rolls up to 30. I said no it
doesn't so I asked the Lord I said what
do you worth per minute he says no lower
your pace by the minute I said I'm going
to launch an app called minute now you
get to connect by the minute and you pay
by the minute hence minute so if you
want to have a face time with Andrew
Tate for 15 minutes you can buy it
matter of fact one of our guys had a 15
minute face time with Andrew Tate put it
on YouTube got a half a million views
another guy put it on Tick Tock got
three million views you can have a
conversation with bodybuilders business
people lawyers you know people who are
raising funds so minute would be the app
I would drive to with today's uh podcast
and that's m i n n e c t you can go to
minute.com and download the app all
right I'm going to download my next
straight after this conversation you
ought to get on minute because I'm sure
people want to talk to you as well I
will do thank you so much absolutely
thanks for having me this was great
absolutely guys thank you so much for um
watching if you enjoyed the show don't
forget to hit the like button And
subscribe and we'll see you all next
week